"...and rival Declan Farmer...he shoots and it's in!" All those years of hard work coming together
and you're getting to hold your gold
medal and you know hear the National
Anthem and sing it along with your
teammates and it's really a special
moment. All those things that happen
right after you win is you know pretty
incredible. "...and Farmer's done it again."
This time we hope to repeat what we did
in Sochi. We hope to win a gold medal
again, we know that's not going to be an
easy thing to accomplish at all
considering how tough the competition is
there's you know a lot of good sled
hockey teams in the world but you know
we've been working really hard. We've had
a good start to our season. We have
great chemistry you know on and off the
ice.